okay so so let's let's jump into this so
basically I want to be on the poster oh
very modest question let's say that we
have a compact set in RN it's given to
us by some polynomial equations and now
what we want to do is you want to take
by some quadratic polynomial equation so
we want to take another quadratic and
optimize it on our set X and so
basically it is well understood that you
know if I want to optimize the ability
to optimize any quadratic sort of
depends on us understanding
algorithmically the cone of non-
quadratics on X right so this is a
convex cone in the set of all in the set
of all quadratics why is that because
you know if I take any two non-negative
if I take any two quadratics
non-negative for next and I add them
it's still non-negative on X and then
you know that's basically the the heart
of sanskritization is that there are
some polynomials that are obviously
non-negative for next like you just
cannot argue about it
what are polynomials that are obviously
non-negative on X well there are some
squares of linear things there is going
to be quadratics and they're not
negative everywhere plus you know I can
add any linear combination of my piece
of my equation because they're just 0
and X so they don't affect any values
right and so yeah this is also this is
another convex cone of sums of squares
on X so these are just polynomials then
can be written as sum of the squares of
linear things plus plus linear
combinations of my constraints why is
that because you know anytime I have one
of these things that I didn't have two
of these things and I add them then it's
still of the same of the same type okay
so we have two convex cones and so the
main question for the talk today is you
know what when does it happen
for what for what sets X does it happen
that all non-negative quadratics are
obviously non-negative or if you want in
a hierarchical formulation when does the
sum of squares hierarchy converge in one
step right that's not going to happen
very often but it's got to happen
sometimes right what can we say
when does their when exactly does this
happen
okay are there any questions at this
point right that that's the goal when
you know when we applied the simplest
sum of squares hierarchy when does it
end in one step yeah I want to know
exactly when does this happen maybe you
could say never you know that I will
give some examples to prove that it
happens at least sometimes right but
that's that's what we want we want to
characterize all of these instances
exactly that's like yeah that's the yeah
in some sense these semi definite
relaxations existed before people
thought about sums of squares see but
now
[Music]
I see all right uh oh no no that oh I
see I see okay I see okay all right okay
so now let me reformulate let me
formulate the same question as follows
so you know basic exotic polynomials you
can also think of them as matrices in
fact many people are more comfortable
around matrices then around quadratic
polynomials and then these what they
want to be really doing well we're
working you know instead of adding
things in L who cares they really don't
affect my value on X let's work modulo L
let's my doubt by all of these guys
because you know they just don't do
anything when X there is zero and X so
why do I care about them and now let's
just the span of my piece okay so then
you know then my cone of sums of squares
is the projection of the cone of PSD
matrices because that's you know that
that's what that's what sums of squares
correspond to all right some of those
squares are PSD matrices and then I'm
you know I'm just working modulo this
working this modulo the span of the
constraints and then the corner sum of
squares is the projection of the cone of
PSD matrices then then what happens if
we look Dulli if we just apply duality
over convex geometry that you know the
dual of a projection is the slice of the
dual cone with the orthogonal complement
of my subspace and you know this cone SN
plus happens to be self-dual which is
very confusing because you never see the
dual and you were right did you see what
we see SN plus so the bottom line is
that the cone the cone that's dual to
the cone of sums of squares is a slice
of the cone of PSD matrices this is a
linear subspace that's all that I want
to say and I say the Sigma X star I
called the Henkel spectra children of X
why is there this Henkel there I will I
will I will explain but in any case then
it's not hard to show that actually so
what we want you know when are all
non-negative polynomials obviously non
negative so non negative polynomials on
X are equal to sums of squares it's if
and only if the dual cone only has rank
one extreme race now let's let's step
back and try to understand what's
happening here so first of all
look at the corner of PSD matrices that
cone all the extreme rates are Rank 1
okay but now I take a slice with some
subspace when I take a slice with the
subspace odds are that I pick up some
extreme rates that do not come from my
old extreme race just imagine let's see
you should I have a notepad but I will
borrow a mere release yeah so if we take
a cone over a laptop case like this
right then if this cone has four extreme
rates these guys right and we have I
take a slice you can see that I all we
know I have to take a very special slice
in such a way that all of the extreme
rays of the slice are actually the old
extreme rays right I mean otherwise
otherwise I lose I picked up some other
extreme rates and that's that's life
that's what happens but you know but if
you did not like if you didn't like the
sum of squares formulation of the
problem which I mean given that in this
workshop that would be strange but
nevertheless if you did not like that
then I offer you another one we want to
take one to understand all of the slices
of the cone of PSD matrices with a
linear subspace that only have Rank 1
extreme race that's an equivalent
formulation of the same problem
questions or concerns at this point so
that's that's what we want to understand
why is this true essentially because
rank one extreme race if you think what
they come from point evaluations on X
that's that is essentially what happens
if they come from point evaluations on X
and it's very easy to understand that
you know what is the Deuter cone of non-
polynomial this is just the span of
point evaluations in the dual space
because if you have all of the point
evaluation then dual two that are
polynomials that are grading are equal
to zero everywhere
that's that's what happens
okay but now I lost this this is
slightly too technologically advanced
now it jumps again okay where are we
okay so now let's do some examples just
so we understand you know what do these
slices look like so some of you might be
familiar with this examples some of you
may be not so the first example is that
we don't take a slice right let's just
take you know our slicing subspaces
everything then of course as I mentioned
the cone of PS DMH is has only rank one
extreme race so that's that's fine
that's our basic you know that's our
basic thing all non- quadratics are sums
of squares right you only have rank one
extreme race okay here is more slightly
more advanced example we take a slice
with the with the subspace of Henkel
matrices
all right so hang committees are
constant and anti diagonals then again
we only theory in chronic stream race
why is that why is that it's because
this actually corresponds to
non-negative univariate non negative
polynomials being sums of squares that's
a dual formulation so then you see that
actually we're doing something that
maybe is not it's not immediately
obvious but the fact you know because
here even though I talked about only
quadratics Here I am picking up an
instance of non negative polynomials of
any degree being equal to sums of
squares and in fact it's not hard to
show that that problem can be reduced to
color to the quadratic problem so we're
actually sort of we're doing maybe more
than we originally might have thought
but that's okay that's good in fact okay
so now here's a third example so let's
say L is a hyperplane and let me just
say it's a hyperbola let's say that
passes through the interior of the cone
of PSD matrices okay so again this is I
guess think engineers called this s
llama implies that basically on the
quadratic all non-negative quadratic are
some sums of squares and then you know
that so the the dual slice happens with
a hyperplane and again you only have
rank one extreme race
okay so and here's maybe one more okay
this is not
so is there any way that I can do this
without making it go all over my [ __ ] I
see just okay just so somehow I'm not
gentle enough okay so so here's a here's
an example that you might not know but
nevertheless it worked what if you
happened basically you can have a block
Hinkle matrix if you have a block Hank
of matrix then you claim that you still
have Rank 1 you still only have rank
want extreme rates in fact you know we
can make it more I can make it more
blocks more block or less blog and you
know so basically it's like it's like I
have Henkel matrices but here you know I
forget that the fact that they were you
know here that the off-diagonal should
continue right that they should be
continued being equal to each other but
here you know they're not they could be
they could be slightly different and in
fact you can think of this as sort of as
a span of tensor products where I take
my just any matrix and then multiply by
Hankel matrix that's what exactly what
happens here ankles is like a chronicle
product and in fact you know in the
background there is some equality
between non-negative polynomials and
sums of squares it's sometimes called
sort of a bi form theorem but I'm not
going to not going to get into that but
I'm just saying so there are more
interesting examples of such things
happening ok and now I want to do in a
sense one more example but it might not
look like that so ok so now we're going
to restart the talk and we're going to
talk about something that looks entirely
different but in fact it's not so let's
talk about positive semi definite matrix
completion so let's say that I give you
a partially filled symmetric matrix so
this is the that's it's already filled
up for you I just asked you to find two
parameters because it has to be
symmetric in such a way that the whole
matrix is positive semi-definite right
now I claim that everybody in the
audience is capable of telling me
whether I can or I cannot do it on this
specific example is it possible for me
to find two question marks so that the
whole matrix becomes positive
semi-definite
there is a yeah yeah I see people so
there is this troublesome minor right 1
2 2 1 there is no way that this can be
erased with the question marks right
this is not positive sad so you know has
a negative eigenvalue and that's it
we're we're out of luck okay
okay so now let me erase this what about
this I change to 201 I still claim that
everybody in the audience is capable of
telling you that I can complete it to a
PSD matrix how can I do this just all
once right that will be easy because now
it's a Rank 1 completion in fact it's
the unique way of doing this but it
doesn't matter for my question okay but
now let's try to graduate to the file -
let's say that I don't that I don't that
I don't tell you exactly what these
numbers are but I'll give you the
pattern these are the known entries
these are unknown entries right and
they're question marks and then I ask
you know when should I be able to
complete it - a PSD matrix well there is
a sort of obvious condition there
obvious necessary condition that we
discover it together so hopefully you
will remember it as an active learning
style right
you know the maximal field in minors
must be positive semi-definite right
there is no question about that you know
if when they're not positive
semi-definite that we cannot do it but
if they are positive semi-definite then
then that's the question you know then
you could ask when is this necessary
condition also sufficient right so when
does it happen adjust by knowing that
filled in minors are positive
semi-definite that the whole matrix can
be completed so now this one I don't
expect if you have not seen this before
it's not the third obvious you know in
this case so now I just gave you the
pattern is it true that once is this 3x3
thing and this 2x2 thing months they're
both positive semi-definite I can find
the question marks is this true or not
is there always true so but I will give
you the answer of course but I want to
say that actually in fact what we're
doing is we're asking about the quality
between negative polynomials and sums of
squares actually okay as you know as we
discovered before you know quadratic
form is a sin well so here that's about
homogeneous polynomials but yes I know
basically a power node we can switch
between polynomials and symmetric
matrices right we can we switch before
from polynomials to symmetric matrices
but now we can switch from symmetric
matrices to to homogeneous polynomials
by just going X transpose matrix X so
let's think about this so if I
only give you partially filled in matrix
I still can evaluate it somewhere at
some points even if even if I don't know
what these question marks are namely if
I look at if I look a point like this
you want so it's in the span a 1 a 2 a 3
means that the fourth coordinate that
the fourth coordinate is zero right if I
if I look if I look if I go X transpose
matrix X where the fourth coordinate of
X is zero then I'm only going to care
about the 3x3 block and then I know the
value right and the same you know the
same you know if I go X transpose matrix
X but I first took coordinates are 0
then I only care about this block and
again I know the value and in fact the
fact that you know in fact the fact that
these two these two miners are positive
semi-definite exactly says that the
field and matrix is not negative on the
set X which just as stage is just the
union of two coordinate subspaces okay
and observe that you know how can I get
X in fact you know what do what do I say
what am I doing when I've seen their
question marks it's like saying that I
don't know X 1 X 4 because that's the
coefficient of x 1 x 4 and I don't know
X 2 X 4 right and in fact X is defined
by vanishing of X 1 X 4 and X 2 X 4 and
that's not hard to see so that's exactly
where the values of these polynomials
don't matter
all right I don't know their
coefficients but their values don't
matter because there is zero there and
in fact so be it so the obvious
necessary condition being also being
sufficient so it says that given a
quadratic form that's not negative on X
that's the fact that the obvious except
that the obvious condition is satisfied
now I'm saying can you find for me the
question marks can you find for me the
question mark so can you add some
multiples of X 1 X 4 and X 2 X 4 in such
a way that the whole matrix becomes
positive semi definite but positive semi
definite things are sums of squares so
what I'm really saying is that you must
find something that is sum of squares
modulo the span of X 1 X 4 X 2 X 4 so
it's exactly like doing sum of squares
on X that's exactly what we were doing
so basically the matrix completion
problem
PhD images completion problem well not
the entirety of the problem but if I ask
when is the obvious necessary condition
also sufficient it corresponds exactly
to asking about the quality of the
quality of between a negative quadratics
and sums of squares okay are there
questions or concerns at this point
maybe answers still the question you
know can I always do it this the
question marks so given let me give you
a theorem so yeah so let me so how can i
how can I sort of a big this notion of a
pattern a kind of more rigorous well so
if I talk about positive semi-definite
completion it's not interesting for me
if I don't if I allow you to choose the
diagonal if I put a question mark on the
diagonal then I can just make this
question mark so big as to rule out as
to basically make the off diagonal and
she's not matter so then I can delete
the row and column so we'll always
assume that on the diagonal the entries
are known so they're always stars on the
diagonal and then I can draw a graph G
where edges corresponds to stars and
there are no self edges because I said
on the diagonal we assume that things
are stars so we just know that this is
the case so here I drew a graph for you
1 2 3 and then 3 4 and then you know the
edges that are missing are 1 4 & 2 4
those correspond to the question marks
missing edges are question marks and now
you know the edges are stars and you can
also see that you know that my set X
corresponds to the maximum creeks and
the graphs like I had the span of e 1 e
2 e 3 and you see the maximal clique is
1 2 3 and the other thing that I had
this e3 e4 and they can help this
maximum clique 3 4 but in any case the
the theorem that I want to state is the
so ready more than 30 years old it just
says that the in my language the obvious
necessary condition is also sufficient
if and only if G is chordal so for
example here it is enough because this
graph is obvious the core so what does
it mean to be a chordal graph it means
that if I have a induce if I have a
cycle of length waiting or equal to 4 in
the graph there must be a cord there
must be an edge between other vertices
of my cycle that I haven't mentioned in
other words any cycle of
ninth grader equal to four has a cord
dividing it that's the origin of the
name cord or if you want you know in
other way the same way of saying is that
another way of saying the same thing is
that there are no induced cycles of
lengths at least four right so here we
only have four vertices there are not
many opportunities for having induced
cycle of lengths for so this one this
for this one it is always true okay so
now what I want you to get out of this
theorem is the is the following
observation so somehow so what happens
here so only in terms of the my set at
defined by quadratic equations what we
really did is we went here for me to be
able to cut so basically the question is
when so it's necessary and sufficient or
one way to say go for non- bound numbers
to be equal to sum of the squares but
another way it's necessary sufficient
that I can just determine the existence
of question marks based on checking the
positive semi-definite of full minors
otherwise if this is not enough I would
need you know there will be some
examples where all the fielded minors
are positive semi-definite but there is
no completion to the full matrix
yeah but the way what I want the way
that I want you to think about this
theorem is that you know basically we
know that globally in being was what
you're doing here is we're gluing
together linear subspaces here there
were two subspaces with the car one
corresponding to one two three one
corresponding to three four right and on
each subspace I do know that non
negative polynomials are equal to sums
of squares but if I glue them together
in a special way in a special way that
corresponds to the graph being chordal
then in fact I still have none the
equality between non-negative
polynomials the sum of the squares on
this gluon
okay all right so now we we get to the
main theorem that I want to state Saudia
so this is joint work with Ryanair sin
and Mauricio Velasco and essentially
what I want to say well so these two
things are equivalent maybe slightly
sketchy so now negative polynomials are
equal to sums of squares if and only if
so what happens so basically we saw
these basic examples where I said there
well that non negative founders are
equal to sum of the squares or I
presented the dual formulations where
are where the well you only had the
extreme rays of rank one so what can you
do how can you how can you will so
basically all examples look like this
you take the basic examples and the
examples that I showed you are almost
the entirety of the basic examples are
almost the entirety of these things
called varieties of minimal degree but
maybe I missed missed a little but I
showed you almost everything and that
what can you do is them you can glue
them together in exactly in exactly the
way that you blue cords or graphs in
fact you need to glue them along
subspaces so you glue them so there is a
sequence in which so it's the same like
the perfect elimination ordering for
quart low-- graphs if you know what that
is you can you can sort of you can
construct the record or graph as a as a
as a sequence of cliques arms over of
just cliques so basically that means
that we are gluing together some
coordinate subspaces but in a certain
very specific order
so here we can also take basic examples
glue them in some water and essentially
what happens is if I take if I take a
union in this order of a bunch of them
and intersect is the next one it's
actually equal to the intersection of
their spans so in particular it means
that I'm gluing them together along
subspaces but also in a really really
special way and and these are all of the
possible examples basically there is
there is not nothing else that you can
do and and these varieties of minimum
degree they are actually quite well
understood they kind of give rise to to
the examples that I showed you with the
with the dual examples yes three line
well I guess it depends on yes really
yeah that that would be bad yes exactly
exactly because it has to be really in
the intersection in the spans yes so
three lines meeting yeah in the triangle
that would be bad okay and you know in
the background there is some there is
some interesting else so I guess I want
to say there is a one message that I
want to say from this talk even though
like sort of push the completely in the
background is that there is something
quite interesting having between
connection between negative polynomials
and sums of squares and some classical
algebraic geometry for example varieties
of minimum degree were classically
studied that sort of at the late
eighteen hundreds early 1900s and then
[Music]
yeah so then and then we're using well
what are these guys you know we didn't
actually discover these guys these these
guys were kind of given to us as
generalizations of varieties of minimal
degree by somewhere move assume well
much more recent work were already from
2000 but in any case they correspond to
exactly varieties or that have castel
nuovo mumford regularity to by that I'm
not going to explain the point is that
somehow actually we knew what the answer
should be or conjecture they should be
before we actually started working on
this problem well there is some
connection to algebraic geometry that
I'm going to suppress
maybe a little bit but there is also
there is another interesting question
that you could ask okay so let's say
that let's say that I take us let's say
that now now that we know in some sense
all of the instances were non negative
polynomials are equal to sum of those
squares what happens if we take so I'm
going to do the dual formulation a time
and if we take a slice of a cone of PSD
matrices and I see new extreme race can
be saying anything about about the ranks
of new extreme race that occur so let me
give you for example a theorem of what
happens so now so what happens if I take
a slice with the coordinate subspace in
other words the slice with the
coordinates of this is exactly the case
of doing the matrix completion problem
so what happens if my graph was not
chordal what happen if my graph is not
cordial then I know that there cannot be
only Rank 1 extreme race but I want to
be able to say about something about the
extreme race that do occur and what
happens is so so let's see so what is
written here let's the number P is the
smallest rank one extreme rate greater
than 1 if and only if P plus 2 is the
length of the smallest chordless cycle
in G so for example basically it says
that if I see a cordless four cycle then
I'm going to pick up rank two extreme
race if I see a cordless five five cycle
I'm going to be covering three extreme
race and this is if and only if if I
picked up or a three extreme array and
if I three was the smallest rank on
extreme rate greater than one they are
not masked then I must have had a five
cycle in my graph and there is also
generalization of this to you know not
to just not to just matrix completion
problems but to let's say two arbitrary
sets X defined by quadratics the so
called property n to P which is a
terrible name and I'm not going to say
too much about what it is but basically
we can also we can also say something in
the case where these two columns are not
equal we can sort of we can say that
maybe in some cases you know they're
really not well many many many ranks of
extreme rates are missing let's put it
this way sir here you go from one
and the next one has to be people has to
see if you don't have any short cordless
cycles then you don't have any small
rank extreme race and that's if and only
if okay so I think this is really all I
wanted to say so thank you oh and this
is this is the paper
one comment the headman's if you think
of these end points the N by n matrix is
also a geometric question where you have
an l2 metric on some subsets of things
and you trying to glue them together in
a to metric on the whole thing because
so this JavaScript composition just
gives in the products and we're just
talking about whether if I give you a
certain subset of distances so this is
very much related this distance
realization problem is very much related
to a matrix completion problem there is
some work by Monique with her I guess
former PhD student that that says that
there let's say if I if I gave if I give
you some specified sets of distances and
[Music]
and then you ask you know is this
realizable in the Euclidean space this
is very much a related problem the only
difference here is because I gave you
the diagonal you could also think of
that that I gave you the diagonal color
corresponds to the norm or I give you
the distance to the origin but it's
almost an equivalent problem for example
you can rescale the diagonal entries to
be one so then you're asking is my set
of distances realizable by points on the
unit sphere and these these are very
might I mean it's almost the same way on
you I think it is almost the same as the
problem of yeah if I you didn't specify
let's say the distances to the order if
you didn't specify the norms
[Applause]